Time is the most valuable thing there is.
Since the beginning of time, there never seemed to be enough of it.
People try to beat time but time always wins.
Sometimes when you run out of time, you wind up doing time.
And even if you're rich, you can't buy more time,...
...although some people will try.
Not having enough time is the basic plot of most action movies.
There's not enough time!
Do your job, Ramirez.
Our greatest fear is running out of time.
And you just spent 34 seconds of it watching this commercial.
Wait, what?
So sorry about that.
There's a bomb in the salsa can, we gotta get out of here.
My phone's still charging!
What?
So, if time is the most valuable thing there is,...
...why would you waste more than you have to charging your phone?
It's not my best work.
The Galaxy S7 Edge with fast wireless charging and our longest-lasting battery.